What a beautiful planet,
a place we always dreamed about.
Earth.
A NETFLIX
DOUBLE FEATURE FILM
The power of all the nightmares
we have accumulated
will turn this world
into a planet of death!
Mamo-chan!
My chest… What was that?
Beautiful maiden.
Save our existence
from this nightmare!
FOR LOVE AND JUSTICE
And it seems the more you hesitate,
the deeper they can get into your heart.
THE ENTIRE
DREAM ARC
We'll sell nightmares
all over the world.
PRESENTED IN
TWO FILMS
Protecting this planet.
That's always been our truth.
Attack!
We can't give up.
You won't defeat my curse.
We have to fight, no matter what.
I am one who sleeps within you.
A memory, you might say.
And it's time to wake up.
Don't forget, this was only the premiere
of the Dead Moon Circus.
We've only just begun.
TO PROTECT
THE WORLD
AND THOSE WE
HOLD DEAR
BEAUTIFUL DREAMS
WILL BE REBORN ETERNAL
Sailor Planet Power!
PRETTY GUARDIAN SAILOR MOON
ETERNAL THE MOVIE
In the name of the Moon,
I, Sailor Moon, will punish you!